Monte Carlo was a sophisticated setting
to show off a teeny-tiny new car giving
the GTI version of the VW up its first
public appearance here was pretty brave
not least because of the cars you
usually see here here Monaco reports our
car man Klaus you see cars that easily
cost a million euros or more for most
people the 30 thousand euros that a VW
Golf GTI costs is already a tidy sum the
up GTI is a cheaper alternative starting
at just under 17,000 it looks like
Volkswagen is targeting a younger crowd
and perhaps minimalists as well
minimalist like Klaus so let's see what
this little guy can do GTI traditionally
stands for power and speed this up as a
turbocharged 85 kilowatt one litre
engine so can it live up to the billing
this mini hot hatch goes from zero to a
hundred and eight point eight seconds
which is not at all bad and to enhance
the GTI feel there is a sound actuator
to let the modestly sized engine roar at
least inside the cockpit bad roads you
certainly noticed that this is indeed a
small car the wheelbase is rather short
the suspension is a bit firmer the
spring and damping rates are very sporty
the front axle has been stiffened and
the rear axle as well so it hugs the
road nicely this up is a true GTI the
ride height has been lowered 15
millimeters and the body widened by 8
that enhances the sporty look and the
handling
among the distinctive GTI features are
the red stripe at the front and the
honeycomb grille which has become a
signature element of newer VW GT is 17
inch alloy wheels are standard at the
rear a spoiler provides additional
downforce it makes the roof look longer
[Music]
the sporty exterior is matched by the
interior the instrument panel has black
and red accents there's also red
contrast stitching on the leather
sporting steering wheel and gear stick
to enhance the GTI feel the seats are
firm and the fabric is a charming tartan
they're a tribute to VW s first GTI
Klaus remembers very well the
first-called GTI from 1976
it has a 110 horsepower engine which was
incredible the new up GTI has 115
horsepower and has a top speed of 196
kilometers an hour which is fine 8.8
seconds from 0 to 100 is also ok fuel
consumption is officially 5.6 liters per
hundred kilometers that could be about
right for a three cylinder single litre
engine Klaus has averaged about 6 liters
but he hasn't been going so fast the up
GTI comes with three or five doors it's
a good 20 kilometers an hour faster than
any previous version of the app and the
tweaked suspension actually makes it
kind of fun to drive the modest engine
does of course have a rather puny sound
but it's boosted artificially by the
actuator inside the car at least the
question is does this up deserve to wear
the GTI badge
[Music]
Klauss sums up of course this little up
GTI cannot match the performance of a
golf or Polo GTI but if you want a GTI
city car that does not cost a fortune
this is certainly not a bad choice